the hive is coming just be prepared with
me today I've got a delightful panel of
Beyonce and mr. Knowles Carter experts
we're gonna break down everything that
went down in that elevator and why
Beyonce is the smartest businesswoman
alive
so let's take things back our story
begins on may 5th 2014 the night of the
Met Gala at the standard hotel it is
rumoured that earlier in the night
Solange had an encounter with the
designer Rachel Roy according to a
source that spoke to People magazine
Solange was provoked and according to
sources at Us Weekly Solange may have
been yelling at a group of people and
Roy was in that crew during the
disagreement the sources that Beyonce
also got in the middle of it however it
is unknown what the fight was about here
is my theory they dragged them into that
elevator they were like this is about to
go down we need to seclude whatever is
about to happen inside her source said
when they got in the elevator it
escalated quickly the way family
tensions can things got further heated
when J's did something inappropriate to
Beyonce and Solange this is what caused
Solange to snap she was like right in
right in the [ __ ] came in ready you're
not very good at blocking either no wait
where's I wouldn't be on site she's in
the corner he's just like soaking it and
goes to go take it take it
she did nothing until she got forcibly
moved yes she's just like oh yeah you
don't step on juban Schuyler lawns like
Mayweather fighting I will say that I
don't like the language that a lot of
people use when describing this like
this Solange attack right I don't think
of I don't know what other kind of word
you would use defense whoa
her sister's honor I'm sorry if somebody
were to be cheating on my sister the way
Jay was cheating on these right yeah
though know what you know I want to talk
about how like collector she was the
entire time it was happening doesn't
like lift a finger except to protect her
dress priorities yeah I think she's the
type of person who saves it for the
house oh yeah good tongue lashing TMZ
acquires this footage at the time this
was a highboy spectacle ten days after
the incident the three of them released
a shared statement about what happened
Jay and Solange each assumed their share
of responsibility for what has occurred
yeah she bought him don't worry about it
the summer following the elevator
incident Beyonce and Jay are on this
massive stadium tour the couple is
plagued by rumors that their marriage is
in crisis mode and there's barreling
toward the divorce that year Beyonce was
also seen house-hunting alone in
Manhattan it's crazy to like go on tour
with your spouse while you're like
potentially imminently breaking up
here's the thing would Beyonce she will
not let you know anything that is going
on until she is ready for you to know
you can speculate all you want like oh
yeah they're going through divorce she's
like we're going on tour together yeah
just the thought of them separating his
seismic I think they're considered
American royalty oh yeah oh yeah
once you add to that contract booboo
there's no no it's like it's as much
business as it is personal at that point
oh yeah in 2016
Beyonce dropped her album lemonade which
included many kinetic references to
infidelity which many suspected maybe
on beyoncé and jay-z's relationship
though at the time it was largely
unconfirmed the album featured a song
called sorry the music video featured an
introduction saying ashes to ashes dust
to side checks at the end of the song
Beyonce concludes by saying he better
call Becky with the good hair the night
the album dropped to designer Rachel Roy
posted a picture on her Instagram with
the caption good hair don't care but we
will take good lighting for selfies or
self truths always live in the light
hashtag no drama queen if you hashtag a
picture no drama queens you're asking
for drama I'm sorry
whoa buy so much tea Beyonce's fans
attack Troy attack on social media
[Music]
Rachael Ray from the food from the eyes
I love how messy the - be let's talk
about lemonade the work of art itself
right there with the Sistine Chapel very
good album um thank you jay-z on your
own on your own
womanly merits sure that album including
myself like helped people you know and
like really help them digest what they
were going through and loving yourself
and having respect for yourself like
those are all I think tie back to that
night
the famous incident lemonade was
definitely like this is what it feels
like to be cheated on and that was put
into an artistic beat well and it's
crazy because one of the biggest knocks
against Beyonce is that she's - like
self constructed and like - poised to
stage whatever she just channeled it
differently alternatively I think that
it's interesting to talk about could she
have released this album how that
incident happens I think without the TMZ
video lemonade isn't as strong
we wouldn't know about her battling back
for being cheated on by someone that she
loves you're absolutely right because we
wouldn't have had that context jay-z's
album 444 was released on June 30th 2017
he referenced the elevator fight in his
album in the song kill jay-z to quote
you egg Solange
on knowing all along all you had to say
you was wrong when asked by Dean bakit
the executive editor of the New York
Times if it was difficult for Beyonce
and jay-z to decide to create
emotionally vulnerable albums Jay
responded we were using our art almost
like a therapy session and we started
making music together
hers coming out first allow us to see
women empowerment before I saw a man
trying to rewrite his wrong there's also
a theory originally posted by Stephen
Osceola on Twitter that Jay named his
album 444 partially because the address
of the standard hotel in New York City
the secondary address of the hotel where
patrons can take an elevator straight to
the rooftop bar is 444 West 13th Street
however Jay had previously told I Heart
Radio I woke up literally at 444 in the
morning 444 a and write this song so
became the title of the album and
everything in the New York Times
interviewed jay-z also admitted to his
infidelity he admitted Trista joke
so you don't come after me we know he
cheated 4:44 is amazing it offered
someone who we never seen long before
tell the truth tell their mistakes their
shortcomings so this has allowed us to
deconstruct toxic Mexico many in the
black community as well on top of seeing
someone openly talk about how they had
to repair themselves for their wife
after cheating he's still human you know
he clearly regretted what he went
through and he showed us I'm not your
bread 1 I'm not your Milotic I need to
earn you back because you are Beyonce I
meant to say about their women who's all
me all mayor's to say that about the
women and we don't want to see the joint
album no Thank You Winston
Beyonce featured has he not been great
on though I'm not saying he's not great
it's just not my style
all right sit down that's the one for I
can defend it in the cheating stuff so
this summer we're getting on the run
hey I got tickets after this
conversation I think that's awesome
Beyonce
drops a tax season every year what is
what is this she's like I know y'all hos
got money
here's another tour here's another album
so they're going back on tour then
staying together like what does that say
about Yonsei and to some extent Ruiz
he's like business sense about how they
handled the entire thing I'm sure that
they had the thinking that like we've
been through so much together why are we
gonna throw it away now like we have
built this really deep love for each
other who do you see jay-z with it's not
Beyonce and I think they very much feel
the same way like there's nobody else
where you go after that yeah yeah the
thought I was trying to someone trying
to stepparent yeah okay mom what if this
has been like a ten year plan right they
were like we're gonna drop this elevator
fight make some bomb-ass breakup albums
and then come back with a tour of us
getting together and they planted over
like a 10-year period like the Avengers
they were like we're gonna do 22 movies
there's all the Beyonce jay-z Solange
expanded universe its transport me there
girl I would live in
[Music]